this is by the numbers where we give you
the numbers that tell the story the
number five trillion dollars women are
increasing their wealth to the tune of
five trillion dollars a year this is as
women control over one-third of the
world's wealth so it's no wonder wall
street sees opportunity in marketing to
female investors and blackrock is the
latest firm to do so the world's biggest
asset manager has created model
portfolios for women which take into
account how women's long-term financial
needs are different than men's and
concludes that women could benefit from
taking on more risk in their investments
at certain times so what does this mean
for how experts advise women to achieve
their financial goals i asked sally
krawcheck she is an early mover in
providing financial advice to women and
founded elevest in 2016.
if i hear one more time
women are risk averse and that's why
they don't invest as much as men do my
head may explode and what i would say
we've noticed is women tend to be more
risk aware what does this mean if i'm
taking on this risk how much could i
lose how much could i gain what could it
look like i want to understand it not i
don't want to take it but i want to
understand it they want solutions for
their problems and one of the problems
they have is when you earn less and you
live longer you risk running out of
money during retirement and so no one
said i want the the one with the pink on
it please for women what they want is
i'd like to have a secure retirement i'd
like to buy the home i want to buy i'd
like to start the business i want to
start
the way we solve it at ellevest is with
a highly personalized engagement through
a digital advisor some would call it a
robo advisor in which they put in their
personal information they tell us what
goals they want to achieve and then we
build a highly personalized investment
portfolio around all of those
characteristics we tell them this is how
much you can afford to invest this is
where the value of your investment
should be within a range over a period
of time we're seeing a really
significant demand for impact investing
and i think part of the move you're
seeing in the investing industry to more
impact is being driven by women they
really are rejecting
the tired well you're going to have to
give up financial returns in order to
get societal returns i just don't
believe it i just don't buy into it you
investing industry then need to work
harder to find a way to deliver both of
those to me
you